[Music]
Game of Thrones is about this huge
Kingdom
it's basically seven kingdoms in with
one ruler one king and you have all
these families fighting for the power of
this country previous king was not a
very nice guy he was a horrible dictator
I was his personal bodyguard and I
killed him when I watched the Mad King
die I remembered him laughing mention
your father ah my twin sister is Sergey
and and we're very close it's a
disturbing relationship in many ways and
he has a line in episode 1 when he says
the things I do for love
when he pushes a kid out of window but
it is truly I believe anyway that he
does it out of love in his very twisted
love I didn't hadn't read the books at
all based on these novels by George
Martin and I hadn't I hadn't read them
so they described this world and it
sounded great and fascinating then they
described Jaime the Kingslayer and then
I think like an hour and into the
discussions oh by the way yeah he sleeps
with his sister and I was like yeah what
was this okay that's interesting
eight nine year old kid being breastfed
by his mum is that crossing the line why
would you say that I have to say that
scene was by far for me like I was like
hmm I remember I was actually that day
they were shooting that scene I had
another scene later on and I came on
said I met some of the crew they're like
oh it's just just wrong that's wrong I
make the kid do that I just but I like
it because I think it's a fantastic
scene because you really I really react
to it when I see it and I know that yeah
it's a it's a fake first of course of
course it's a fake breasts you know yeah
what I hadn't experienced that before
and on anything I've done that maybe
also because of the internet today and
and because of the fans of this show are
very vocal and like but but with the
reaction to an episode is is instant
it's like you know Wayne right Twitter
wait what I all those things and and it
was funny to see how after episode 9
when that star is executed so many
people cook ever gonna watch that show
again it's the worst show ever I'm hated
I hate that hate and hate it of course
then the ratings went up next and it
what's great about it's like we talked
about that early about passion if you
want people to be passionate mean if
people are passionate about a show
that's a fantastic thing even if they
don't like the directions the show is
taking but the fact that they get that
invested in the characters that it
almost seems like you've killed one of
their loved ones it's it's it's I mean
I'm so grateful to be part of this I
really